[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
january 4th
2019. i'm megan cantwell on this week's
show i talk with contributing
correspondent
tanya ravis ratatana about plan s
an initiative for publishing open access
research
what's holding back other research
funders from joining
i also speak with louis stone about his
quantitative approach
to understanding one of the most deadly
periods of the holocaust
in september of 2018 science europe
announced an initiative called
plan s the plan requires that
researchers use funding from
any institution signed onto the
initiative to publish their work in an
open access repository or journal that's
available to everyone by 2020. i'm with
tanya robis sandratana to talk about how
research funders
and countries have been receiving this
plan hey tanya
hi megan so what institutions have
currently joined this plan
right now we have 16 institutions from
13 different countries that have joined
the
coalition s as it's called and that
includes
one private funder from the us the bill
and melinda gates foundation
and some major funding agencies from
france and the united kingdom and also
smaller agencies from other countries
you mentioned before that the bill and
melinda gates foundation signed on to
plan s and they also previously did
require open access as a mandate to
using their funding so what is the
difference between
what the gates foundation used to
mandate
and how does it change that they've
joined plan s the gates foundation was
definitely a pioneer they
they've already been requiring immediate
open access
uh since 2017 but planets goes even
further because it
also targets hybrid journals hybrid
journals are
journals that make money both from
subscription
and from article processing charges so
that's what is called double dipping
and planus days we don't want double
dipping
we want how we journals to shift their
business model to complete open access
and they require written commitments to
do so
within a certain amount of time the case
foundations they didn't target
hybrid journals at the time and now
they're aligning with planners and they
are saying
they will crack down on hybrid journal
publication too has there been a lot of
interest in other research funders
joining plan us
they have been statements of support
at the time of the plan was launched in
particular there were several
letters that accompanied the plan and
the list of
of funders so agencies did say we
support the goals of planets
but we're not quite ready to join for
this for that reason so what are the
main reservations for funders who
haven't signed on yet
planets is is quite radical most funders
already have open access policies
they're already required to clear the
grantees make their scientific papers
available for free but they generally
allow six month or
month delay and planners requires
immediate open access so it goes much
further
and it also has a very short timeline
to begin action on the 1st of january
2020.
so for a lot of funders this goes a bit
too far too fast some funders
would prefer to take less radical action
and they want the research community to
kind of shape their open access
transformation from the bottom up
rather than imposing top-down rules it's
not
just research funders who are involved
in plan s that of course also
impacts researchers as well what has
been the general reception by
scientists to this initiative so the
reception by scientists was really
mixed the vast majority of scientists
aren't
aware i think of planets it's fair to
say that so far it's uh
it's a policy plan that hasn't yet been
implemented so they don't see the
difference in their grant contracts and
the obligation that have changed for
them
but for open access advocates who
followed these very closely they have
been very strong reactions sometimes
very emotional reactions
some people think fundamentally it's the
way to go
if the institution that has the money
decides
to mandate this then it will definitely
happen
and other thing it's too radical it's
too far too soon
too restrictive and they would like more
options to publish in different
venues or they would need more time or
they would want more more detail to know
exactly what would happen
yeah and on the other side there are the
publishers of this research
what has been their concerns not all of
them have
responded i think a lot of them are
taking the time to
see exactly what's going to be the very
very fine print of plan s
some publishers have said that we'll
work with the planets funders
and to find a solution that works for
them and to adapt and continue to
have a business model that works for
them and others are kind of
waiting and we don't yet know if they're
going to be cooperative
it's the big question is are the other
publishers going to playable
or not are they going to wait until the
very last minute
although open access publication means
it's free on the user end to access
there's a fee associated with publishing
the paper though is this something that
plan s discusses
open access doesn't always involve a fee
i think that's a very
important point to take on board there
are
ways to publish open access without fees
planets does focus and some critics at
the beginning thought there was too much
focus on this
gold business model when researchers pay
a fee to a journal to have their paper
published open access
and planus says funders by sign
entrepreneurs will pick up the bill
for these article processing charges and
we will
cap them they want to make sure that
article processing charges are not going
to skyrocket
and that the market is a little bit more
even and fair
one important thing to keep in mind is
that not every region has the same
publishing practices
some publishers are saying that they're
not going to buy in until
all funders join in on this and based on
your research
does it seem likely that there's going
to be a lot more people joining plan us
in the coming months so based on our
research uh yes we know that some
agencies are planning to join
some of them need more time it's kind of
a big geopolitical game
there might be some peer pressure for
funders to say okay this group of
funders is opening the door to something
really radical
we also want in or on the contrary they
might say oh i just i'd rather wait and
see what happens
with this group of people before i
commit myself
at the time that planets was launched
they were there were 11 funders
now it's already grown and it's been
four months it's already been five more
agencies have joined and then in
december china say
they support the gold of planets without
saying that they will formally join the
coalition they say we completely support
the goals of planets and
mention very similar measures to planets
so that weight of
a good number of agencies from europe a
very clear commitment from china
is definitely significant it's not
an isolated project it's it's taken a a
global
flavor even if these countries don't
join
plan s by saying that they are also
committed to open access that could also
still have a sway on publishers then
if they align their policies to the
basic principles of planets without
signing formally
it's less powerful obviously because the
alignment will be
possibly less strong but if they go for
similar measures then it can definitely
have a very big impact
we're still a little ways away from the
2020 deadline are there still some
aspects of plan s
that may change in the upcoming year the
basic principles of planets are not
going to change
they're a very short set of 10 brief
principles and the team behind panelists
has made it clear that they will not
open those for discussions
but the implementation guidelines that
haven't released in november
are open for feedback until the end of
the month
so looking forward on how this might
impact research culture in the future
some people contend that publishing in a
journal with a high impact factor has an
influence on
hiring decisions how would plan s change
this
planus says that they support the san
francisco declaration research
assessment
which says that research needs to be
assessed on its own merits and not on
the basis of
which journal it was published in so
they say the
funders who sign on to planets intend to
sign the san francisco declaration and
to
implement their related policies for
research assessment
this is not a binding requirement so
it's a little bit fuzzy
how the change will happen obviously if
you change the publishing culture
you don't only change the place where a
paper is published
this has an impact on the whole
publishing system
so the way that you typically decide
who to give money to for a research
proposal or who to recruit who to
promote
all these things are tied with journals
and especially the journal impact factor
the people behind planets hope that by
changing
the publishing culture you will change
the research culture more broadly
all right thanks so much tanya thank you
tanya robeson ratana is a contributing
correspondent at science
you can find a link to her story at
sciencemag.org
podcasts stay tuned for my interview
with louis stone about quantifying the
kill rate
during the holocaust
[Music]
i'm here with louis stone to talk about
his research being published in science
advances which
quantifies how fast the nazi genocide
occurred
during a particularly deadly period of
the holocaust
hey louie hi there megan first off i'm
curious what your background is and how
you arrived at this topic that's
at the intersection of both math and
history
sure i work in mathematical biology and
a lot of my work deals with
modeling diseases and epidemiology a few
years ago i got interested in the spread
of disease
during the holocaust because disease
played a large role
as it happened i came across an
incredible data set that
outlined disease in the warsaw ghetto
where there was a huge typhus epidemic
it's a case that's not very known about
and so i've been studying this data
quite a bit
while doing this i came across other
documents and other data sets and that
led me to my
larger work on the holocaust your
research center specifically around
operation reinhardt and that was one of
the largest murder campaigns
of the holocaust could you give some
background about this event
in january 1942 arguably
was the one c conference when the nazis
finalized on the final solution to
eradicate all the jewish population
and they began with operation reinhardt
which was all the uh
jews in occupied poland and there were
close to two million of them
and they were to be obliterated within a
year
so operation reinhardt itself took 21
months
in terms of the procedure the nazis
built three
death camps treblinka belzek and sobibor
and the idea was to round up all the
jews from all the communities
in occupied poland to train them in
large train loads to these three
different camps
and then to gas them and to kill them
and that they did
within hours of arrival at the
facilities
this operation occurred during just one
period of the holocaust
how are you able to evaluate this
specific event
that's the crux of the issue in fact
this specific event has been overlooked
for
uh decades a lot of concentration was
put on auschwitz
in the years after the difference being
that
auschwitz there were survivors and so
there was data and diaries and accounts
that were much more easily accessible
what happened in operation reinhardt
though was meant to be a total secret
the nazis destroyed all data
and there was a 99.7 kill rate anyone
who went into any of those three death
camps
didn't come out every five years i
looked for material
on this and then i i found this book by
a famous holocaust historian yitzhakarad
he wrote a book on operation reinhardt
at the back of the book there's this
appendix with all the train
transportations listed in occupied
poland
giving the location the date the number
of victims
and the destination at which this jewish
community would be transported to
meaning which death camp
so we know the times they were
transported we know the places from
which they were transported from
and we have a good estimate of the
numbers so what did you learn about the
time
frame and the rate of murder during this
operation from those railway transport
records
well i have to tell you at first i was
very reluctant to
input the data because these are
people's lives and you really feel it
we put the data in rory and i and
we saw the time series and then i got
quite a shock
because what you see is over 21 months
you see a low level killing rate
relatively i mean there's still a lot of
killing but then in the months of
august september october there was half
a million
500 000 people each month murdered
that's like 15 000 people per day now
what would happen at say a facility like
treblinka
you could have two trains in a day which
is like 10 000 people in a day and they
would be murdered within hours upon
arrival
it's really vast this is a scale of
murder that you wouldn't think possible
and it requires large-scale organized
support to enable it
it was a pure focused genocide in which
the jewish population just didn't have a
chance
why is it that this particular event
happened so fast
i think this was the uh most organized
operation
it really set out to target a large area
collect all the jews in that area and
kill them murder them within three
months
i mean it was like i said a focused
genocide deliberately designed to do
that
it's the largest and fastest scale
genocide that i know of
what caused the end of this intense kill
rate so after three months
there were very few uh victims left in
occupied poland to collect
so the germans had basically finished
their job so
when you look at the graph the killings
just suddenly stop
and that's an indication that they've
run out of jewish people to kill
yeah there's also another implication
because it lasted three months
not only is it not widely known you can
do a search
in books on the internet you won't see
it they won't give you any time frame it
happened over 21 months or it may have
happened over six years
this is the first time i believe that
it's really isolated down to the bulk of
the killing happened in three months
so if you think about it how is the
victims supposed to
come up with any organized resistance it
would be impossible
i mean the event was over before it
almost began
do you think this will change how
historians characterize the holocaust
it will definitely add to the
interpretation of a very large part of
it which
is not widely known i show these graphs
to people all the time
and they're quite shocked no one
realizes that that's how a genocide
could work they always see it in other
terms
like you hear six million jewish people
died in the holocaust but
your mind cannot latch on to that huge
number
it's you can't grasp it but you look at
these grass
and you really catch what happens yeah
and you mentioned in your research that
textbooks often compare other genocides
to the holocaust like the rwandan
genocide and
some textbooks say that this genocide
had kill rates that were
three to five times higher than the
holocaust and your research
suggests otherwise so what do you think
the importance of this research is in
contextualizing
other genocides there is a big field of
comparative
genocide it's now become standard that
yes the rwanda genocide was the uh most
intense genocide of the 20th century
all genocides in 20th century considered
including the holocaust
so for example samantha power the ex-u.s
ambassador to the un
stated that the rwandan genocide was the
fastest most efficient killing spree of
the 20th century
and many many other comparative genocide
scholars tell us the same
well they just don't know about
operation reinhardt and
it could be because that information's
not out there so i'm hoping
my study will rectify that but it's a
whole field of comparative
genocide studies if you use their
estimates to work out what the rate of
the holocaust was
they underestimate it by a factor of 10
and the
holocaust was at least double the rate
of the rwanda genocide
what does it tell us about comparative
genocide studies it tells us
to be very careful when you go and do
these comparisons and preferably don't
do them because
it's not helpful and usually there isn't
data available to do it well
and why do you think it is important to
take this quantitative approach to
characterizing genocides there's now a
whole new science of quantifying wars
conflicts and genocides
so if you look at modern genocides
there's great efforts now being
made to characterize the war casualties
and the different types of war
casualties whether they're civilian or
not
so there's huge efforts put into it so
that we don't get it wrong again
and that we really know what happens
because like i said going back to the
holocaust there isn't much data
available
that makes it so hard when future
generations really want to understand
what goes on they'll get stuck you know
there's not
any modern statistics and believe it or
not there's not even one graph you won't
find grass of it
and this is such a data-hungry age is
changing that way faster and faster so
quantifying is very important because it
becomes more tangible evidence
there are attempts to quantify but they
don't they don't have data so
it's a real uh problem all right thank
you so much louie
thank you louis stone is a professor of
biomathematics at tel aviv university in
israel
and of mathematical sciences at rmit
university in melbourne australia you
can find a link to his paper
published in science advances at
sciencemag.org
podcasts and that concludes this edition
of the science podcast
if you have any comments or suggestions
for the show write to us
at science podcast at aaas.org
you can subscribe to the show anywhere
you get your podcasts
or you can listen on the science website
that's sciencemag.org
podcasts to place an ad on the science
podcast
contact midroll.com this show was
produced by megan cantwell and sarah
crespi and
edited by potachi jeffrey cook composed
the music
on behalf of science magazine and its
publisher
aaas thanks for joining us